[Applauso]
come si accelerano le emozioni e le
consapevolezze nel dolore
quante volte nella nostra vita nel
momento del dolore ci siamo resi conto
di ciò che siamo oggi sono qui per
raccontarvi la mia storia sono lisa
martinetti e sono figlia d'arte
io ora vi chiedo un respiro quando
sentire un bel respiro
perfetto
avevo 8 anni quando morì la mia bisnonna
chiamata da noi non una vecchia
la ricordo molto bene
ovviamente vecchissima ai miei occhi nei
suoi 98 anni aveva questi capelli
lunghissimi che sembravano dei fili di
seta
una donna che aveva perso il marito
molto giovane ed allora aveva sempre
indossato il lutto fino al suo ultimo
respiro
quei capelli di seta per lei erano il
suo punto di forza
li trattava con cura il pettinava li
spazzolava con tanto amore la stessa
cura e lo stesso amore che io ebbi con
lei quando la vidi riposare all'interno
di quella che allora per me era definita
una scatola di legno
era bellissima
io ancora vivido il suo ricordo
con questo nero quindi questo colore che
ha fatto parte della sua vita
e questi capelli bianchi che
incorniciavano il suo viso
immaginatevi voi le manine di una
bambina di 8 anni che accarezzava i
dettagli di quel viso di quella donna
vissuta ma soprattutto che con cura
sfiorava quei capelli
ecco quello fu il mio primo contatto con
la morte quella che io chiamo la grande
signora
finito il funerale tornai a casa e la
prima cosa che feci presi un foglio
bianco e disegna i su di esso una bara
circondata da fiori
da allora sempre avuto molta attrazione
bianche attenzione verso i cimiteri
per molti il cimitero è un luogo triste
perché all'interno di esso regna la
morte
in realtà se voi provate a fare un giro
tra le tombe e osservate le fotografie
sembrano ancora vive alcune sorridono
riguardano
ricostruire quelle vite c'è molta
pienezza all'interno di esso il grande
rispetto non necessariamente religioso
difatti io dico sempre che all'interno
di un cimitero c'è molta più vita che
morte
nel nostro paese
purtroppo
quando
alcune persone vedono passare un carro
funebre
fanno ancora gesti scaramantici
ma io invito queste persone a provare a
guardare questo mezzo in maniera
totalmente differente
provate a salutare gli operatori che
sono all'interno sono delle persone che
stanno accompagnando una vita un ricordo
perso un grande viaggio
in alcuni paesi addirittura in alcune
culture si organizza una vera e propria
festa per il proprio ultimo saluto
io lo trovo un gesto d'amore immenso
ritrovarsi tutti insieme
ricordare il proprio caro è un momento
di condivisione
un gesto immenso ed amore puro
che io ebbi l'esperienza di fare tre
anni fa con mio padre un grande
guerriero
insieme a lui pianificando il suo
funerale
mio padre era un operatore funebre ecco
perché sono figlia d'arte
per arrivare qui oggi ho fatto un
grandissimo viaggio nel dolore
nel dolore e nelle mie fragilità
e ho capito dopo aver pianificato il
funerale con lui che dovevo trovare un
senso questo dolore
qual era il senso di stare accanto alle
famiglie nel momento più delicato è più
doloroso
è così lasciai un lavoro a tempo
indeterminato
quindi una certezza e accolto e scelto
il cambiamento
e ho deciso di diventare una funeral
kanner
il mio compito è di accompagnare le
famiglie verso il viaggio del dolore di
accompagnarle soprattutto nella scoperta
del dolore
perché grazie ad esso spesso si possono
trovare delle sfumature di vita
e anche rinascere proprio come è
successo ma
ho deciso di prenderlo per mano il
dolore di onorarlo fino alla fine ho
deciso di esserci per queste famiglie
famiglie che con un gesto e uno sguardo
mi consentono di portare in alto il nome
del proprio caro
famiglie che in quel momento
stanno affrontando una perdita quindi
una mancanza
e così ho deciso che questo era il mio
compito
grazie alle mie fotografie
sono riuscita a dar vita ad un luogo che
appunto per molti è definito un luogo di
tristezza
sono riuscita a dar vita
ad un luogo di profonda connessione
se voi ci fate caso all'interno di esso
regnano i ricordi ricordi di famiglie
almeno vite
riguardando le fotografie voi potrete
così ricostruire e raccontare
quelle vite che rimarranno sempre vive
nei cuori di chi rimane
spesso mi viene chiesto come faccio
a continuare costantemente tutti i
giorni a stare in contatto col dolore
quella tristezza dentro nelle case delle
persone che hanno appena perso un caro
entro in punta di piedi
perché so quello che stanno provando
spiego spesso sempre
che la mia è una vocazione
quando deciso questo forte cambiamento è
stata una decisione dettata proprio dal
cuore il mio lavoro nel mio lavoro
metto tanto amore l'amore di cui hanno
bisogno le altre persone ma questo non
vuol dire che dietro la mia greco la mia
corazza non si nasconda una fragilità
anzi
eppure
spesso si parla di vita non mai di morte
poco di morte si ha paura della morte da
si teme
eppure sono due facce della stessa
medaglia
proprio come il bianco e nero delle mie
fotografie
con mancare è un nostro caro il nostro
genitore un nostro fratello una nostra
sorella nostro amico un collega
un figlio o una figlia
a mancare non c'è soltanto una vita a
mancare c'è una persona che lascia i
suoi ricordi la sua famiglia
lascia un lavoro lascia la sua città
ecco perché sono facce della stessa
medaglia
chi rimane nella disperazione e chi
invece se ne va sapendo di lasciare i
propri cari nella disperazione
c'è molta intimità nella morte
moltissima
la stessa intimità che diverbi con mio
padre
avendo pianificato il funerale con lui
mi ha permesso non solo di volerci
essere per le famiglie ma di sorreggere
il dolore di accompagnarlo fino alla
fine
essendo operatore funebre
un giorno mi disse
pisa io sono malato
è giunto il momento di parlare del mio
funerale
immaginatevi voi una figlia seduta al
tavolo con il proprio padre
chiti guida dandoti le giuste
indicazioni
su come doveva essere il suo funerale
aveva scelto tutto la perfezione tutto
dal legno della cassa dal modello della
casa addirittura gli interni mi
raccomando lisa non voglio questo colore
dalla musica dai brani
finché si alza va in camera ritorna da
me
mostrandomi il suo vestito questo è
quello che indosserò
ecco perché dico che c'è grande intimità
nella morte
c'e grande intimità nella morte
perché per me quello è stato il momento
più intimo non solo quella signora con
mio padre
fino a quel giorno è sempre stato lui a
prendersi cura di ma in quel momento
invece ero io a prendermi cura di lui
ecco perché quello che dico sempre io
verificare il proprio ultimo saluto è un
atto d'amore che si fa verso se stessi
ma soprattutto verso chi ami
perché
perché te ne vai lasciando comunque le
tue volontà e la famiglia non deve far
altro che accogliere e ascoltare il
proprio dolore
credo che bisogna
assolutamente
accogliere
il dolore ma soprattutto il dolore della
morte
perché grazie ad esso riusciamo a
renderci conto di ciò che siamo e di ciò
che potremmo diventare
parlarne è il primo grande passo
ascoltare e ascoltarsi
e un altro grandissimo passo oltre
passando così il tabù della morte
sono lisa martignetti sono una funeral
planner e oggi mi dedico alla cura dei
defunti ma soprattutto alla cura di chi
resta
[Applauso]